olá eu sou a professora cissa é esse é
meu avô e meu tio
vocês podem ver que o look é moderno
simples ser caiçara é um estilo de vida
é ter proximidade e necessidade de estar
junto à natureza e essa definição ela é
importante que a gente faça disso um
ensinamento porque a natureza em são
sebastião é com certeza o nosso bem
maior é a mistura dessa dessa definição
de ser caiçara em mim tem a ver com
índios tupiniquins
coloquei um colarzinho aqui a ilustrar
negros é franceses e obviamente os
portugueses
essa é minha avó e neta de um negro
alforriado e uma índia tupiniquim
o meu avô ali do lado filho de
portugueses
eu e os meus irmãos essa é a casa da
minha família e é uma confusão de
geração de etnias negros é índio sttrans
eses portugueses e isso cria uma
confusão porque a gente não tem tradição
alguma
se a gente fosse definir enquanto o
cachorro nós seríamos o puro vira latas
que tem um pouco de tudo a gente à minha
avó e neta de escravos jogava pipocas em
cima da casa para proteger todo mundo
segundo ela e meu avô né católico
apostólico romano de antigamente com o
seu terço na mão logo dizia e apontava
você vai pro inferno por causa disso ea
gente ali venda tudo aquilo então essa é
um pouco né da minha vivência essa casa
é na frente da bahia do araçá
olha aí a banda nasceu maria linda
maravilhosa
até pouco tempo a gente chamava de
mangue do araçá mas por conta do
da dos ensinamentos de pesquisadores
gente resolveu falar mas é mais chique
fala bahia horas aí a gente absorveu
isso então assim as chances podem vê lá
ao fundo que tem o porto hoje ele está
bem mais próximo desses filhotes que
vocês vêem aqui próxima da onde a gente
tá tinha história das etnias e ainda
somado a essa confusão toda que eu
cresci ouvindo os meus familiares de ben
agora o porto vem ea gente vai ter que
sair de novo porque na década de 30
minha família foi desalojada de uma
praia que era a continuação ac de onde a
gente tá chamada dariam então assim pra
minha família era comum já se imaginar
fora do lugar onde vivia e eles achavam
que era isso que acontecer em 1788
nós tínhamos estimadamente 3500 pessoas
sendo que mil eram escravas
imagina a falta de iniciativa e de poder
é de acreditar que se podia realmente
fazer alguma coisa para mudar então e eu
tiver sorte né que de ter estudado só
aqui em escola pública de ter ótimos
professores que me chegaram a estudar ea
pensar refletir sobre a importância do
que isso tudo representava e aí eu fiz e
educação física com o objetivo de manter
essa minha proximidade com a natureza
porque imagina imagina eu vou dar aula
na praia nem vou dar aula de canoa vou
ficar vou trabalhar ganhar dinheiro que
eu preciso
mas vou manter ainda essa conexão que eu
tinha com a natureza e trabalhando há 15
anos e baixam eu sou servidora pública
já 26 anos é eu fui apresentado a um
trabalho com um grupo de terceira idade
ea cada dia que eu via o treinamento
dessa desse grupo e ver que assim se uma
pessoa ficasse gripado logo perdia tudo
aquilo que tinha construído ao longo de
dois meses
eu comecei a ficar engarrafado com
aquilo que já aprendeu alguma coisa e
claro que aquilo foi fazendo eu fui
fazendo uma ligação com o meu próprio
corpo e eu fui eu preciso ter alguma
coisa diferente pra colocar para esse
público e eu comecei a estudar o yoga ea
yoga fez toda a diferença porque aí eu
comecei tudo o que eu ia fazer
olga e hoje dei 77 anos sem ser
professora porque era muita confusão
saber que aquilo tinha um peso de
responsabilidade muito grande
só que eu pirei sem saber já é uma piada
porque achava que o gol tinha que ser
para todo mundo não só paixão e aí eu
achava assim são sebastião precisa ser
capital de alguma coisa que seja boa pra
que a gente tem aqui na frente ea bela
capital da vela ao lado caraguatatuba
capital do vôlei do vôo livre
mais adiante o batuba capital do surfe
falei bem e outra tudo a ver da conectar
tudo e ainda de quebra a gente vai
atrair gente do bem porque quem pratica
yoga do bem quem está aí sabe né que a
gente quando começa a praticar ioga a
gente adquire propósito compromisso com
a vida eu falei bem agora eu achei o meu
caminho
só que eu tenho nesse sonho executiva do
yoga ressurge a conversa de novo de um
fantasma pavoroso que era a ampliação do
porto e aí o yoga pra mim começou a ter
mais conexão ainda porque o era plantio
com yoga canoagem yoga tudo yoga e aí eu
tinha que fazer alguma coisa em relação
a essa questão da ampliação do porto
nesse mesmo teatro foi apresentado por
um alto executivo bom que a só da metade
da palestra dele que o lembrei que era
contra dizendo que o porto seria
ampliado em 42 vezes do seu tamanho
atual
e aí comecei a ficar desesperado que não
é a hora que foi dada a oportunidade da
palavra eu e os caiçaras aí ô ô ô ô o
executivo lembra falou calma professora
os caiçaras vão ganhar um museu do cairo
zakaria nós eu imaginei meus tios
empalhados meu irmão com a física de
pegar a tainha assim né
eu falei meu como vai ser eu sei que eu
devo ter descambado fala tanto até a
hora que ele me cortei falou o professor
essa é uma visão muito apaixonada pronto
nasceu
os apaixonados pela mãe e aí são dez
anos de luta de conversas de palestras
de muitas saudação ao sol na praia
lembra o yoga e eu continuo acompanhando
só que a gente fazia saudações ao sol
que a gente faz e depois
olha o que a gente faz também parte
china estão convidados porque é isso que
a gente faz a gente teve um abraço ea
nossa coisa mais importante são as
regatas de canoas que a gente tem já dez
anos mas mais importante relação a tudo
isso a gente não se amedrontou contra
uma história que por pela maioria das
pessoas estava certa
a gente é conseguiu juntar duas mil
assinaturas e eu fui apresentado a
realidade não se baixam a maioria das
pessoas que a gente conversava era a
favor do porto da ampliação do porto num
modelo que estava sendo proposto ea
minoria assim como eu
mas diferente de mim um pouco acreditava
que a gente não podia fazer nada então
aquilo foi mexendo comigo ea gente foi
fazer os movimentos até que a gente
resolveu ter uma fala mais afinada com
os pesquisadores
e a gente tem hoje nós primeiro livro
projeto biota ver precisam ser baixam
movido pelo nosso ego de trabalho e
também por algumas bobagens que alguns
políticos acabaram falando de que a
bahia já estava morta e tudo mais
e esses pesquisadores e 170
pesquisadores que 35 instituições entre
nacionais e internacionais
e hoje nós temos o nosso primeiro livro
a gente tem muito a comemorar neste
momento porque a licença prévia expedida
pelo ibama está cassada então e o
próprio porto hoje no chão para
conversar então a mensagem que eu tenho
aqui tá acabando meu tempo
a mensagem que eu tenho aqui pra dar pra
vocês o seguinte a primeira coisa o yoga
é um caminho para a gente desenvolver o
autoconhecimento ea gente define um
propósito que seja importante para
ji-paraná para as nossas vidas e aí
definido esse propósito a gente não pode
criar nem observar muito tamanho do
obstáculo quando nós começamos a nossa
luta como apaixonados pelo mãe nós somos
chamados de davi porque obviamente
golias é o governo do estado mas em
nenhum momento a gente jogou pedras e
golias a gente sempre queria chegar
próximo de golias para conversar e aí a
minha mensagem é o seguinte independente
daquilo que seja o tamanho da nossa luta
é que é muito muito importante que a
gente mantém
a ponte do diálogo sempre firme e
independente da correnteza que passa por
baixo ou do vento que passa por cima a
ponte do diálogo ela precisa ser mantida
e é isso que os apaixonados pelo mãe de
hoje podem comemorar
nós somos nós somos chamados para
conversar pra falar prova disso que eu
estou aqui nesse momento
obrigada por todo mundo